dans quelques minutes sur antenne 2 en
direct de la sorbonne un grand échiquier
exceptionnel jacques chancel
je vous entends très bien quand on
dirait dans d'autres émissions
bonsoir jacques ce soir vous avez décidé
de faire l'union entre des artistes et
des chercheurs des savants oui je crois
d'abord que c'est une bonne chose que de
faire se rencontrer et la musique et la
science et j'espère que ce soir nous
allons y arriver d'abord parce que c'est
une grande cause
il s'agit du conseil pasteur weizmann
vous avez so2 grand temple de la science
ce sont des endroits où vraiment des
chercheurs travaillent d'arrache-pied
pendant des années des années et comme
je le disais tout à l'heure on parle
souvent de beaucoup de jambes et ses
savants ces chercheurs sont bons c'est
un peu leurs rôles sont trop souvent
anonymes alors cette soirée est
organisée ici en direct de la sorbonne
il fallait à la science un endroit comme
celui là avec l' orchestre symphonique
de jérusalem est qui est aussi
l'orchestré de la radio et de la
télévision et puis il orchestre de north
bay jupille alors vraiment énormément
énormément d'invités j'espère que tous
ceux qui sont là avec vous claude
thiriot nous ferons l'amitié de nous
suivre et parmi nos invités yves manteau
j'ai voulu pour vous claude qu'il soit
près de moi merci jacques on vous
retrouve dans quelques minutes pas ce
journal pour un grand échiquier
exceptionnelle en direct de la sorbonne
à tout à leur merci